así es comienza la etapa masiva de
aplicación de vacunas como bien lo
mencionabas con la llegada de este
embarque de 430 mil dosis hasta ahora la
el promedio de vacunación por día era de
6 mil 6.500 pero ya con este arribo y
con la regularización que habrá cada
semana de dosis de facer comenzará en
todo el país la aplicación de vacunas a
personal médico que está en la línea de
batalla del 'hobbit' 19 actualmente
únicamente la ciudad de mexico el estado
de coahuila y nuevo león estaban
inoculando al personal de salud y a
partir de este día será en cada uno de
los mil quince hospitales que hay en los
32 estados dedicados exclusivamente al
cómic 19 a partir de febrero comenzará
la aplicación de vacunas a adultos
mayores y se espera que este periodo
abarque hasta finales de marzo cuando
muchos principios de abril y después a
toda la población en general esta etapa
de vacunación en adultos mayores será
por rangos de edad de 80 a 79 y de 80 a
70 años después de 70
a 60 y así irán paulatinamente
expandiendo la aplicación de vacunas que
hay que recordar que es en dos dosis en
esta vacuna de facer y a partir de ella
mismo comienza una brigada de médicos
militares y funcionarios de gobierno
serán mil brigadas en una primera etapa
y se espera que durante la campaña de
vacunación sean 10.000 brigadas en todo
el país
inoculando a la población el que méxico
vaya adelante mário en américa latina'
en la vacunación es un logro para andrés
manuel lópez obrador criticado por su
gestión de la pandemia es que ciudad de
mexico es uno de los focos del
coronavirus
así es el presidente de lópez obrador ha
dicho que a pesar de las críticas de
méxico está en el segundo lugar de los
países de américa latina con más vacunas
aplicadas ya lo mencionadas en 87.000
únicamente por debajo de argentina y
bueno esto se debía a que los embarques
eran de pequeñas cantidades el primero
el 23 de diciembre fue de apenas 3.000
dosis el último el más reciente del 5 de
enero fue de 53 mil dosis pero a partir
de ahora pues ya comenzará de manera
regular esta inoculación a la población
y por ello pues el presidente ha dicho
que es de los principales países no nada
más en recibir las vacunas sino en
comenzar a aplicarlas puesto que ya se
tiene un protocolo de vacunación y no
hay que esperar almacenar esas vacunas
para después ver cómo empezar a
aplicarlas sino que es de manera
inmediata y pues esto se supone que
tendrá un alivio para
situación crítica que se vive como bien
lo mencionas en la ciudad de méxico-
está en un punto máximo de saturación de
hospitales con más del 91 por ciento de
ocupación hospitalaria y las
restricciones para los comercios han
vuelto es decir los restaurantes por
ejemplo no pueden dar servicio al
interior del establecimiento lo que ha
generado pues algunas protestas del
sector restaurantero y de la iniciativa
privada en el sentido de que la crisis
les está pegando muy fuerte y muchos
tendrán que cerrar sus puertas si no hay
un plan emergente de apoyo las
autoridades han dicho que únicamente se
ofrece la exención del pago del impuesto
sobre la nómina pero la situación en la
zona metropolitana de la ciudad de
mexico es crítica